[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hey
welcome to the table looks like people
are still filling in come on in we're
starting
my name is Karen
happy last weekend of September
and from what I hear the weather is
going to follow suit maybe in the next
couple days let's hope so I'm ready for
fall hey kiddos
I have a couple of announcements tonight
um
first of all do you want me to do that
one first all right
you guys check out Brittany and her
t-shirt turn around see the bag
look at those you guys asked and we
delivered so Brittany Mindy and Maggie
have been working on new t-shirt designs
for us and this is a mock-up that
Brittany did uh we're gonna do a bulk
order of this design has all of our
values and another design with our table
logo which this is a smaller oh Maggie
has the table logo on her t-shirt uh we
are going to do these in a couple
different color options one is this
really pretty green and then with the
other one the red or the blue the red so
the red that you see on on the banner
here on the sides we're gonna do the
shirt in that color as well so the
shirts will be twenty dollars uh and
we'll go towards the table so it's a
fundraiser support uh opportunity as
well and we hope to get these in uh
towards the end of October so that we
can celebrate our three year anniversary
of the table together in style
and then also we can wear these to the
centerpiece conference anybody that's
going to that it's a great opportunity
to wear your shirt and also you can wear
it wherever you want because why not
they're great thank you Brittany
um if you are interested in purchasing a
shirt we'll have kids sizes we'll have
adult sizes
um and uh if you get Brett's weekly
email he will include a link to order
t-shirts on that so if you already get
Brett's e-letter you are good to go just
look for that next week the link will be
on there to order and then if you do not
get Brett's weekly email grab one of the
visitor cards it's out on the little
tiny table out outside of the door put
your name and your email address and
check the box for send me table
newsletters and we'll make sure to
include you on that and then you'll get
the information for the shirt as well as
Brett's weekly e-letter which is always
full of great stuff sound good oh and we
do have some extras of the shirt that
Maggie is wearing she has them with her
15 bucks
yes these are the old the Vintage shirts
yeah so if you're interested in one of
those she has
um some sizes so if you're interested in
one of those for 15 bucks see Maggie
after the service
cool and then the other announcement I
have this is very very important because
it is regarding our service on Sunday
October 23rd we're switching our service
time from 5 P.M to 11 A.M and we're
gonna join in with Pleasant Valley
United Methodist Church the church that
meets here that we rent the building
from you guys they're celebrating their
160th anniversary as a church that's
amazing it's amazing to me
um and we want to join with them in that
they have been so so supportive of our
church our values our inclusivity
um they have been incredibly generous
with renting this space out to us for
not a lot of money
um and we want to just we want to join
with them in the celebration we want to
stand with them like they've stood with
us and so mark your calendars Sunday
October 23rd 11 A.M right here uh we'll
join with them in their service they're
doing a lunch uh afterwards that we're
all invited to so plan to stay for lunch
afterwards and we'll give you lots of
reminders of this so you'll get it in
the e-letter and probably a text message
as it gets closer but just wanted to
give you a heads up on that all right
how about if we take a moment to Center
ourselves
remember what brought us here
connect with your breath
your heartbeat
life can get so busy yeah close your
eyes life can get so busy
we can forget to just stop and press the
pause button
and Sunday nights in here is a great
time to do that
so just take a couple breaths
think about why you're here
what you hope to get out of tonight
you are welcome here you are loved here
you are included here you can be
yourself here
God we Center on you tonight we remember
that you are the source of peace and
Hope
and Grace
and God I pray that you would
be very present to us tonight and
whatever is needed whether it's a word
of encouragement
reminder that we're not alone
healing
reconciliation forgiveness
love
that that has experienced here tonight
and it would be undeniably you God
so we open our hearts and our ears to
you God
pray that we would surrender and trust
you at deeper levels
and that you would reveal yourself to us
in new ways
healthy ways
encouraging ways loving ways
that help to
tear down walls and open us up to your
love and your grace and your goodness
God
in Jesus name I pray amen
all right if you guys want to stand with
us we're going to get started
we didn't even get to pray before our
practice or before our service so I was
soaking that in Karen just a moment to
be quiet because it has been like one of
those
straight through like go go go
afternoons and one thing that I love
about
coming together as a church and starting
off our night with worship is that it's
not a concert but it is like a campfire
sing-along so whatever we come in here
with we come together you know and
whatever we bring to this time of Music
we bring it together we share our
offering together and so I just want to
invite you guys into this sing-along
with us
um whether whether you enjoy singing or
you enjoy listening or clapping or
dancing or sitting and absorbing this is
a space for us to come together so um
y'all join in with us and this first
song
um really kind of illuminates that whole
concept it's crowded table by high women
so
um all right you guys sing along if you
can if you want
[Music]
you can hold my hand
s
when you're feeling highly low
I can be a street like
showing you the way home
you can hold my hand
S
I want his house
[Music]
[Applause]
in the day is done
if we wanna Garden
[Music]
[Applause]
see
can I what a house
[Music]
foreign
for this city Texas
[Music]
for the old and the sick for the Widow
and orphan for the injured and suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and for all who remember
and care for them
we pray to you Lord we know that you
love us and that you hear us and so we
lift these names and situations up to
you
[Music]
from online healing for James's mom's
arthritis foreign
[Music]
for the names and moments we have spoken
aloud and for those we have kept in our
hearts we pray to you that they may have
life and light healing and hope peace
and a deep sense of your presence amen
thank you
as a rise
strength of God
go before
Lift Me Up
as I wait
the lies of God
look upon
my size
as I wait
a heart of God satisfied
it's the same
as I hear
voice of God
lead me home
be my guy be my guy
above and below me before and behind me
in every island sees me
All Around Me Above and Below
before and behind me in every eye that
sees me Christ be all around me
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
every moment in your life
[Music]
[Applause]
above and blow me
for and behind me in every eye that sees
me Christ we all around
and below me before and behind me in
every island before
[Music]
[Applause]
text me
[Music]
Christ be all around me
above and below me before and behind me
in every eye that sees me Christ be all
around me
[Music]
before and behind me
in every eye that sees me Christ be all
around me
so I think you that you are with us
you are here
and you promise not to leave
you are a God who stays with us
this next song is called another in the
fire and it's largely written around
that concept of Christ being the
presence with us in all things and I
don't know if for you if you can think
of a time when you were at a low when
you were carrying a heavy burden
maybe for yourself or for someone else
and despite the loness despite the pain
um
in the midst of it all somehow you felt
like your arms were being held up for
you somehow you felt like there was a
presence there sustaining you even at
your worst even in the midst of the pain
um
for me that has been true in moments and
because of that I can sing a song like
this in honesty and um we were having a
discussion this week and to be truthful
uh there are some of us that
um are experiencing a lot of pain right
now
on the stage in this room
we're going through it you know or we
have people very close to us who are
going through it and it can be really
hard sometimes to sing words like
some that you might find in this song
that at first glance can seem a little
um
cliche like I count the joy in every
battle because that's where you'll be
and you can read that word by itself and
think you know what no there's no joy in
this battle this is not joyful you know
when you're watching loved ones suffer
or maybe you yourself are suffering from
um relational or physical or mental pain
it can be very hard to read those words
and think that there's any truth in that
and and I will be the first one to admit
I don't like singing songs that don't
feel true and if it's not true for all
of us then I really struggle to even
present those as something that our
community should join in with
um but we looked up the word joy in
Greek and Hebrew and
um you know what came up was so
interesting it was the word grace
and sometimes I feel like we need
um some context around our lyrics or
around our scripture to really
understand what we're saying
and Joe and Josh have been in the middle
of this is Joe and Josh for those of you
who might be new
um so their family has been experiencing
a lot of pain with a niece who has
recently been diagnosed with cancer and
has just been going through the worst of
it and watching their brother and
sister-in-law go through the worst of it
watching a child who is suffering in
real physical pain and not knowing what
tomorrow is going to bring not knowing
it is they're going to be healing on the
other side of this is there going to be
an answer is there going to be a
solution and
um so we had some honest dialogue around
this song like can we sing this from an
honest place can you count joy in every
battle you know but whenever you
whenever you think of Grace and that God
is showing up in our worst moments and
giving us Windows of Grace and sometimes
that looks like the people around us it
looks like Josh and Joe being there for
them and the extended circle around them
who's saying we want to be there to pray
for these people to lift up this little
girl to you know be expecting good for
Harper you know
um and and put that name in it for you
who is it that was on your heart tonight
when we were leading prayers of the
people who is it that you've been
carrying or maybe your own battle and
can we look for those moments of Grace
and and do we believe that God is
showing up and he is with us and we're
never alone in sometimes that's the only
thing that we can hang on to sometimes
it's the people that are around us who
are believing for us and that's the only
strength that we feel in that moment so
as we approach this song Whatever your
pain is whatever your struggle whoever
you're carrying I hope that you can find
those little pockets of Grace
those little pockets of presents and
hang on to those
because that's where God meets us that's
where we believe he is at his best is
when we're at our worst
foreign
[Music]
and when I look at the space between
where I used to be and this Reckoning
I know I'll never be alone let's sing
this there was another in the fire
fire standing next to me
there was another in the waters
holding back the Seas and should I ever
need reminding
of how I've been set free there is a
cross that bears the burden
where our mother died for me
there is another in the fire
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my death
beneath the waters
I'm no longer a slave to my sin anymore
[Music]
and should have fallen fall in space
between oh what remains of me and this
Reckoning
[Music]
the world
finding a pound
there's a thing that holds nobody and
now the power lives in me there is
another in the fire
[Music]
there is
the light in the darkness as the
Darkness Falls to him
[Music]
nothing stands between us
like
foreign
[Music]
Joy of every battle cause I know that's
where you'll be
and I can see the light in the darkness
as the darkness
[Music]
[Applause]
between him
[Music]
nothing stands between
us nothing stands between us nothing
stands between there'll be another in
the fire
standing next to me
there'll be another in the water
holding back the Seas and should I ever
need reminding
how could you been to me I'll count the
joy come every battle cause I know
that's where you'll be
I'll count the joy come every battle
cause I know that's where you'll be
there
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
God we just trust that you're beside us
you go before us
you stand behind us
and you're within us
[Music]
your presence is always accessible
your love is ever present and constant
and no matter what we face
God we trust that you will be there
[Music]
how we just take a moment to Center
ourselves
and whatever fear we hold in our hearts
God we just hold that open to you and
ask that you made us there in the middle
of it right now
[Music]
I just encourage you to pray out whether
it's out loud or just in your heart just
speak out name the fear if there's
something that's coming up that you know
that you're scared about that you're
caring would you just name that
and hold it up to the light of Jesus the
light of his love
[Music]
please
God we trust you with these fears
we trust you with our pain
our struggles
and we're grateful God that you're with
us through it all
You'll Never Walk Away
[Music]
we love you and we're grateful for time
together grateful to hold these burdens
for each other
to hold up one another's arms when we're
weak
[Music]
God it's a privilege and would we
remember that
would we look for ways to be loved to
each other to be community and light and
life and healing
be with us tonight as we go about the
rest of our week would you be here would
you be near
it's in your name we ask all these
things
amen
thank you guys for being in that space
together with us and as you're sitting
down will you just turn to the people
around you we're already kind of seated
but just make them feel welcome and at
home and loved here
well good evening
Grace and peace
so good to be
with all of you tonight and my name is
Brett for those who don't know and the
pastor here and I want to welcome all of
you as always that includes those
joining us online y'all are not
forgotten and um and anyone here who is
new
um maybe just kind of finding your way
into the community or just visiting for
a time we're just we're really glad to
have you with us Jesus was incredibly
hospitable kind welcoming
um which as we'll get to in a moment is
like the whole series we're in and uh so
we seek to live into that we do it
imperfectly but we're trying and so I
hope you've since that um that welcome
and love and just know that you are
really um not only just welcome here in
like some formal sense but really you
wanted
um here we we really are grateful that
you're with us so
um we are in a series right now titled
unclean uh Drawing Near and runaway
world and
um we're basing this series this is off
of a book by a Christian Author and
psychologist named Richard Beck so his
book is also titled unclean and
um I knew at the beginning of the series
I knew if I said hey everyone just get
this book and read it you know maybe
three of you would do it uh everyone's
busy so I'm like okay we'll just do the
theories and uh so I'm doing my best to
kind of recap it so definitely if this
if these sermons were like a paper they
would be like plagiarism you know
because I'm putting in my own words but
still like I am drawing very heavily
from his uh his book and it really is
it's a I mean it's a marvelous marvelous
book so at the end of this series if
you're inspired you should go back and
um and read it because I mean it's
really obviously it's about 200 whatever
pages so you know I can only kind of
touch on things
um he really admits it's marvelous
um so really our kind of Hope of the
series is simply that
um we we come to see the life and the
ministry and the love of Christ in a new
way you know there's something about
like church and sermons and the
scriptures and such which can all get
um I don't know a little kind of just
overly familiar you know and it's sort
of like oh yeah I've heard it I've heard
it I've heard it I get it I get it I get
it
um and uh at least if you've been in in
that world for a while um so I I hope to
kind of make the familiar strange a
little bit in this uh this series so
um so kind of throughout the series
we've been we've had this recurring
um passage the scripture like in ways
the whole book is a reflection on
Matthew chapter nine uh and specifically
verses 9 through 13. so I want to go
ahead and start with a reading
um this this short story of The Life of
Christ it says as Jesus Jesus went on
from there he saw a man named Matthew
sitting at the tax collector's booth
follow me he told him and Matthew got up
and followed him while Jesus was having
dinner at Matthew's house many tax
collectors and sinners came and ate with
him and his disciples when the Pharisees
that would be the religious leaders of
the day when the Pharisees saw this
they asked his disciples
why why does your teacher eat with tax
collectors and sinners in other words
with unclean people
on hearing this
Jesus said it is not the healthy who
need a doctor
but the sick
but go and learn what this means I
desire Mercy not sacrifice for I have
not come to call the righteous but
sinners
so uh in week one we talked about
disgust psychology some of you remember
this because the first 10 minutes were
really gross we were talking about
there's everything we find disgusting
um from you know mold on food to I won't
go back through it all but it's just you
know the gross things of of life and
we're just like oh know
um and what we named though is uh the
that there's kind of a danger right the
danger of disgust is the way it invades
our moral imaginations it is not merely
things that we come to view as unclean
as disgusting but people
right that's the key and you can see it
in the story right that we just read
like you hear it in the Pharisees
question why are you eating with them
implication being those unclean folks
right so that was kind of week one
um week two which was last week
um we started to kind of name why this
issue is particularly a problem for
religious communities because you might
think like well you know Christians and
you know worry about love loving people
you know so why is it all of a sudden
that we really struggle with this that
in essence it's very easy for churches
and um and even just individual
Christians to start becoming what we
might call pharisaical in that way
um and so what we kind of what we named
um is that a because churches and
Christians are really um kind of
passionate about uh you know you could
say love but really sort of right living
you know what does love look like it
means you do the good and you avoid the
bad things right and you can see how
that very quickly Becomes of uh be with
the good people and avoid the bad people
all right can you see where we just it's
like a little adjustment but oh what an
adjustment it is like huge implications
of that huge ripple effect into how we
connect with people and what they I mean
it's interesting how you can be around
someone and just send
that like
they don't like you and not only do they
not like you but it's like they
especially if they're maybe religious or
whatever it's like oh they they think
I'm kind of unclean you know morally
speaking
um this becomes a huge issue so this is
why Jesus says um go and learn what this
means Church Folks
I desire Mercy
not sacrifice
in other words not not more Holiness
Holiness understood in a specific way as
stay with the with the good with the
quote unquote clean the pure that you
know stay there Sean stay away from the
bad like he's like stop it learn what
this means I desire Mercy in other words
um a love that crosses the chasms
that Holiness constructs right can you
see that I desire Mercy compassion great
love not more wall building
transcendable move beyond the walls and
don't build the walls higher
as uh it seems
many in My Tribe of Christian faith are
often doing it
um now
where I want to go this week this is the
title of the message this week is cracks
and fissures and what I want to do in
this message is help us see
um how this might actually be a
challenge for us
because I I think based on kind of that
recap I just gave you
um you could probably see or start to
think yourself like well
um I can see like yes I even saw a few
you know heads nodding sort of some
amens maybe I don't know if we said it
we're not really a big amen Community
Nikki Parkers and she's like a community
of one back there's like she's like yes
amen
um but you know on the whole it's not
really the totally Vibe
um but you know I know you were thinking
like yes I see it right you guys see it
like it's not like huh that's been the
church or that's that's a problem I
don't think so you know no pretty much
everyone's like yeah yeah I've seen it
experienced it yeah
um so I think the challenge
um as they come to this week I'm
imagining some I'm calling it push act
that might be overly negative uh I don't
mean it negative since I mean like there
might be some questions in the back of
your mind of like okay
so how does this like actually relate to
us and like as something we might
actually
um struggle to live into ourselves
obviously
um
there's a lot of folks here
um because we're an affirming Community
lgbtq affirming there's a lot of folks
here who have been on the we'll say the
receiving end of this sort of judgment
and uh I'll just go and study say it BS
like just a lot like just on Amen that
thank you Lori thank you right so we've
had a lot of so there's certainly that
which was really week one I was trying
to really speak to that and name like
this is the thing right
um
but with I think we could sort of see
like okay but this is really a problem
in other churches
right like not the table we don't do
that here it's like the whole heartbeat
of the church what are you talking about
um and and what I want to I want us to
see something a little bit um more more
subtle so the pushback might go
something like this you might say um
Brett social moral discussed this seems
to be related to rather extreme forms of
exclusion
um dehumanization that like this is not
me I don't like I'm not really going
there
um and as you'll see at some level I
agree right I'm not yeah
um but uh oh well to go on this like
think of like I mean at at a really
crazy level like think of how this plays
out not just like in my individual life
or a church or something but imagine how
this plays out in like a nation a
country oh it's called genocide
right like that's where this starts to
because what is it's like well we're the
pure
we're the clean where the whatever it is
you know I mean the upright the
righteous ones the uh and we've got to
get rid of those right you think um The
Madness of like Nazi Germany
um you think of the uh Jim Crow and all
of the Just hellacious years of racism
and lynching I mean just write the the
tragedy of of all that like or even in
very modern times like think of um
Westboro Baptist some of you may know of
them
um I don't even it's not like they're
not Baptist I'm not sure what their
theology it's it's just uh for those who
are not in the loop they're
um just openly homophobic and racist
stand it's just like yeah it's just the
worst of religion like it's not subtle
at all you know usually it's kind of
subtle but no not there
um so it's right I think as we do a
series like this it's like say that's it
like that's the evil that's the and I
like I am certainly not that
um and uh so like I mentioned what I
want us to see is something a little bit
um more more subtle so here would be
maybe how I'd sum up some sort of
response would be like this well
um it's true that social moral disgust
is often
um is related to extreme forms of
exclusion and dehumanization
um that's true but the early warning
signs we might call the the little
cracks little
means of that
um of that dehumanization that's
that's there
that's present
in all of us you say no not me
well
it's in me
um there's a quote this is from Richard
Beck he says racism and Hate
don't just emerge out of the blue
just like whoa where the what where did
that come from I can't believe it
doesn't just emerge out of the blue he
says the research which we'll get more
into in a moment the research concerning
dehumanization this is dehum you know
this is sort of seeing others as
may be subtle or sometimes as we named
not so subtly
um seeing that there's this sort of less
than human you know like I am like
really and me and my people we're kind
of you know full Rich emotionally
complex
people with a story you know deep
stories and dignity and you know with
those others
not so much
um
these this the research concerned
dehumanization suggests that the
fissures run through every human heart
in good times with good people you know
so in other words low stress
these fissures might not amount too much
but during times of stressed and panic
oh gosh
these fissures begin to crack
open
now what are these these fissures these
these um
these kind of cracks of dehumanization
that Beck's name there's a lot in the
book he goes all through I'm giving lots
of examples of this
um a lot of it boils done is something
that might surprise you something very
very um basic and this is why it's
actually kind of in us all it is um
really kind of rooted in our preference
for something as simple as the people we
know and like and trust you know good
people
verse
those others
and this starts at a very very young age
just think of like um for example like a
newborn
there is a time in a season where you
can pass a newborn
around right stranger walks up you're
just like here you want to hold Maybe
like oh maybe they're a little
uncomfortable
you know but the newborn doesn't care
right newborn's like oh okay
now we all know I'm uh I I know the
exact dates I'm sure child psychologists
have like at 18 months they're at 22
months or whatever but we all know at
some point what shifts
oh you try to pass off that your darling
little angel and all of a sudden all
hell breaks loose right it's like what
happened you used to be so friendly to
everyone and now just like ah right and
the child of course can't verbalize it
I'm basically the child is saying
stranger danger I don't recognize these
I don't know what would be pheromones
whatever they're picking up on you know
like they're just like I don't know you
and get me back to Mama or daddy or you
know like right this is this is what's
happening now
um
this is this is the the fissure the
opening because of course as we get
older
um our we might call it our our moral
Circle our our Circle of Care of course
it expands right it doesn't just stay
with like nuclear family or hopefully if
it if that's what happens that's not a
good thing right it's sort of like no
over time of course we have friends we
have maybe even here like church to me
like we have folks that enter into what
we might call our moral Circle
and they're they're in right and um and
it's those folks that we learn we learn
to love at least if it's like working in
a sort of normal human psychological way
we learn to love the folks um in our
group
um
where we start to struggle is sometimes
with those
outside
um Becky gives a wonderful example of
this he talks about uh imagine one like
Friday night
you go out to a restaurant but you
choose a specific restaurant
because you have a friend uh she's a
waitress and it's like her first night
on the job and of course you want to go
there you and your friends you want to
surprise her so you look forward to like
the night you're gonna you know request
to sit in her Section You're Gonna Leave
a big tip you know just like play it up
right
um so let's imagine you get there to the
restaurant and the place it is packed
and then you catch the eye of your
friend
and you right you know her well and you
can see oh no oh she is stressed out
right and sure enough she gets to your
table a little late she gets to your
table she's like yo I'm so sorry
I'm stressing out I'm behind on like
every drink order every food order
please please show me some Grace tonight
I'm doing my best you know I'm learning
um now the question is how would you
respond
would you be like Cross Your Arms be
like hey hurry up like I hope not right
no of course not you'd be like hey hey
hey hey hey hey hey for a week here
ignore us right like just
if in the next half hour we could order
that'd be great but you know I mean like
on the whole like just don't worry about
us you go ahead and take care of
everyone else every other table like
just do that we're fine don't worry
about it right don't stress correct like
this is what of course this is what we
would do now this leads to probably
um maybe a good time to bring up our
second form of maybe a pushback that's
coming through your mind from last
week's message that I just recapped
earlier about you know crossing the
chasm and such um you might say
something like this Brett C and the
waitress example I consistently choose
not perfectly but I consistently choose
to extend Mercy Grace
um to my family to my friends to my
community
um I rarely if ever build walls of
exclusion and dehumanization
um and of course at some level and I
agreed right I know y'all like you're
very kind people
um it was wonderful
um however here's the trick the deeper
challenge is to extend that same mercy
and Grace to every person strangers
Outsiders
enemies included
like that's the challenge because let's
imagine a very different scenario Friday
nights you and your friends go out this
time Noah waitress friend
y'all know where I'm going
yeah no
you get to the restaurant it's packed
you sit down the waitress takes forever
I mean just to get a drink order it's
like 20 minutes and then when she
finally brings it like of course she
forgets like one person's drink order
gets another person's wrong everyone's
lacking straws and that's gross at a
restaurant like yeah yeah back to
discuss psychology like uh you know like
is there just it's and then the orders
laid and it's just you know my gosh and
throughout the like At first you're like
I'm patient I'm patient I go to the
table I'm trying to do this well you
know um but it it just builds in you you
know I mean like the frustration and the
just the sense that so the anger grows
eventually you complain to the manager
you leave little if any tip
um
why
why the difference
well it's because
the second waitress she's outside the
circle
she I mean honestly
if you had to pick her out of a lineup
like some sort of there's a crime there
there's a PL you know you have to pick
her out of a police lineup
three hours later
you know what I mean it would just be
like
you know
Becky he sums it up this way he says in
a very deep psychological sense
This Server wasn't really human to me
she was part of the backdrop of Our
Lives
part of the teeming
Anonymous masses
towards which I feel what do we feel
indifference
fear
frustration
what's going on here
why this subtle process of of
dehumanizing
why do we do this
I think there's a lot that goes into it
but at least one piece is because we
have a tendency
to um
break the world into groups
and then to ascribe to our group
whatever that group is you know certain
positive characteristics
that we tend not to ascribe to others at
least not so easily
you know even and this happens like any
way you carve up the world whether it's
something as basic as we've been talking
about like the people I know the good
people
you know I mean people I know
verse those strangers I love Beck's
phrase the teeming Anonymous masses of
humanity
you know just the other so whether it's
something like that
um or whether it's
um even like Democrats Republicans
right Christians Muslims
um
just however you do it
and and what happens whatever group
you're part of you tend to ascribe
certain
positive things
you know so you think um well you know
Muslims that's that's fair they're very
fanatical
yeah all of them
but us Christians you know we're very
like we're just moderate and very
reasonable
and it's like have you have you met a
Christian yeah
um
or this is my favorite one in uh the
culture Awards we have going on you know
um Democrats and Republicans
you know now Democrats
they're just wimpy
but you know those Republicans like
they follow facts rather than feelings
you know or to reverse it
you know Democrats now they're
compassionate that's the compassionate
party the party of compassion
Republicans
bigots
all of them
right can you see the like yo where
we're doing it
just we keep it's the little cracks and
fish and like back name it's
just come out in the open you know
especially when stress levels are low
that's sort of quiet on the inside
we just maybe like the Facebook post or
whatever you know but nothing's that I'm
not going on a huge rant you know I just
I just
um
but it's when times the stress hit
oh gosh that's when things in our own
lives our own Families Our oncoming
churches countries the world you know
this is it it goes crazy
um
there's uh this is a quote Claude Levy
Strauss he says humankind he's an
anthropologist he says humankind he's
thesis at the border of the tribe
in other words there's my tribe all
those others and we're like
you know
um the way one way I might just try to
sum all of this up is the subtle impulse
to dehumanize that is always with us
always with us quietly watering the
seeds of disgust Within
there's a wonderful I'm going to close
with this a wonderful commencement
speech
by David Foster Wallace it's pretty old
now so many of you have heard it this is
water
by David Foster Wallace if you haven't
heard this the audio from it
um go ahead online this week and check
it out I have I've quoted before a
different portion of it in a different
sermon but
um I love it because he it's like one of
the most unique commencement speeches in
that
um
he talks about parts of life
that most speeches to graduates whether
it's high school or college or whatever
he's doing a one to college students at
Kenyon College
and he talks about how you know a lot of
those speeches like it's so much Reach
for the Stars you know it's like all the
grant grandiose visions and such that it
kind of Misses that large part of our
life like would it would it actually
consists of which is things like working
seven to ten hours a day at a somewhat
boring job or getting stuck in traffic
and trying not to become furious with
everyone around you you know like this
is actually so much of our life kind of
consists of so he wrote this speech that
was trying to speak to that because he
says what's going on in our minds during
those times
well it's basically what Beck's name is
it's the cracks and the fissures how we
start to think of others so notice in
this section of the speech that I want
to read notice
um how it slides from kind of a subtle
dehumanization at first it's subtle and
then it just starts getting like it's
the disgust impulse raring its ugly head
just to be clear he's not saying this is
good he's saying this is what we do and
uh oh it's not good so uh David Foster
Wallace he says this by wave example
let's say it's an average adult day you
get up in the morning you go to your
challenging white collar job your caller
who's speaking to college graduates so
that's his Assumption of those folks
um you work hard for eight or ten hours
at the end of the day you're tired
you're somewhat stressed all you want to
do is go home have a good supper maybe
unwind for an hour then hit the sack
early
can I get an amen because that's all I
want to do in life eight o'clock bedtime
I would like but my kids go to bed at 9
30 and 10 p.m and 10 30 sometimes that's
what it seems
um
so he says uh but of course uh because
of course you have to get up the next
day do it all again but then you
remember
there's no food at home
you haven't had time to shop this week
because of your challenging job and so
now after work you have to get in your
car drive to the supermarket it is the
end of the work day and traffic is apt
to be very bad so getting to the store
takes way longer than it should when you
finally get there the supermarket is
very crowded because of course it's the
time of day when the other people with
jobs also try to squeeze in some grocery
shopping anyone getting some anxiety
just from his description like oh my
gosh what nightmare in the store I love
his description he's a very good writer
the store is hideously lit and infused
with soul-killing music or corporate pop
and it's pretty much the last place you
want to be but you can't just get in and
out quickly you have to wander all over
the huge overlit stores confusing aisles
to find the stuff you want you have to
maneuver your junkie cart through all
these other tired hurried people with
cards and eventually you get your supper
supplies he said now it turns out there
aren't enough checkout out lanes open
even though it's the end of the day rush
so the checkout line is incredibly long
which is stupid and
you can't take your frustration out on
the Frantic lady working the register
who's overworked at a job who's daily
tedium and meaninglessness surpasses the
imagination of any of us here
but anyway you finally get to the
checkout Line's front you pay for your
food you get told to have a nice day and
a voice that is the absolute voice of
death
then you have to take your creepy flimsy
plastic bags of groceries in your cart
with the one crazy wheel that pulls mad
neatly to the left all the way out
through the crowded bumpery bumpy
literary parking lot they have to drive
all the way home through slow heavy SUV
intensive traffic rush hour traffic
everyone here has done this of course of
course but this hasn't yet been a part
of you graduates actual life routine day
after week after month after year but it
will be this is a remarkable
convinciency John it will be and many
more dreary annoying meaning less
routines
but that's not the point
the point is that petty frustrating crap
like this is exactly where the work of
choosing is going to come in because the
traffic jams and the crowded aisles and
the long checkout lines give me time to
think this is the important part gives
me time to think and if I don't make a
conscious decision about how to think
and what to pay attention to I am going
to be pissed and miserable every time I
have to shop because my natural default
setting is the certainty that situations
like this are all about me about my
hungriness and my fatigue and my desire
to just get home and it's going to seem
for all the world like everybody else is
just in my way and who are all these
people
in my way
hmm
and look
at how repulsive
can you hear the discussed language look
at how repulsive most of them are
stupid
cow like dead-eyed
and non-human they seem in the checkout
line
look at how annoying and rude it is that
people are talking loudly on cell phones
in the middle of the line and look at
how deeply and personally unfair this is
now he knows his audience then he shifts
or of course if I'm in a more socially
conscious liberal arts form of my
default setting I can spend time in the
end of day traffic being disgusted about
the huge stupid Lane blocking SUVs and
Hummers and V12 pickup trucks burning
their wasteful selfish 40 gallon tanks
of gas
and I can dwell on the fact that the
Patriotic or religious bumper stickers
always seem to be on the biggest most
disgustingly selfish vehicles
driven by the ugliest most inconsiderate
and aggressive drivers and I can think
about how our children's children will
despise us for wasting all the Futures
Fuel and probably screwing up the
climate and how spoiled and stupid and
selfish and disgusting we all are
and how modern consumer Society just
sucks
and so forth and so on
now
10th
I think
wonderfully insightful analysis of
exactly everything we have been talking
about for three weeks
but it's just how it plays out
in here
right I wouldn't say this stuff
just
I think it
thank you
because if we aren't careful
we begin to do what he described we
begin to build walls
walls of dehumanization walls of us in
them walls of moral judgment but what
does love do yes love calls us Beyond
the Wall yes we're called to love our
friends love our family love our church
community and so on right yes
but that's just step one
just step one
what's step two
to go from there
and begin to love the driver of the
vehicle with the bumper sticker
you despise
the stressed out waitress
that we barely notice
the people in our way at the grocery
store
the person we find offensive at the
office
in other words to love the people who
love me
that should be a given
but to love those outside my Circle of
Care
the teaming Anonymous masses of humanity
that takes attention awareness
in vigilance
so what might this look like in your
life this week
ask your waiter or waitress their name
treat them like your best friend
speak to your janitor at work
make friends with someone you disagree
with politically or religiously
believe the best about the driver
cutting you off
look for the best in religious or
political Traditions you disagree with
pray for someone you believe to be
irredeemably horrible
imagine your worst enemy as a child
see yourself living their life becoming
who they become
this is how we can begin to cross
boundaries
that disgust notes
so as we come to the table of the Lord
tonight
we come as the people
who God
crossed the boundary to reach us when we
were in our worst moment when we were
um at least feeling unclean like an
outcast
while we were the Bible even used the
language of strangers to God
heck strangers to others and even of
ourselves
Christ in his
death and Resurrection crosses the chasm
and so as we come forward tonight that's
what we're remembering that's what we're
participating in as we take in the bread
of Christ symbolizing the
um the body as we take in his blood it's
what's in the wine uh it's a moment of
reconnection
with the one who loves us
so this is the table
not of the church but of the Lord and
it's made ready for those who love him
and for those who want to love him more
so come
you who have much faith and you who have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here alone you who
have tried to follow me and you who have
failed
come because it's the Lord is this
and it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet in the mirror
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
all right
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
it's called Brokenness Aside and it's
kind of just a confessional
of um how we are all
we are all coming before God as people
who are flawed we all have our issues
and our Brokenness and our mistakes
we're all going to screw it up but we're
trusting that he will do his good work
in US and continue to change us and
transform us and make us into better
versions of ourself
so um if you guys want to stand with us
as we sing this last song
Joe's going to lead us
foreign
[Music]
cause all
I know
is
[Music]
The Sinner if it's not a one thing it's
another
caught up in words Tangled in life
you are a savior and you take Brokenness
Aside and make it beautiful
beautiful beautiful
[Music]
will you call me
your child
in my tell you
cause
[Music]
I am a sinner if it's not a one thing
it's another
caught up in words
beautiful
[Music]
you make it beautiful
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
for being with us tonight I hope
something in this service touched your
heart and reminded you that you were
loved and you're not alone and you are
among friends here
um both in this room and also those
watching online
don't forget we have the visitor cards
that are right outside this back door
and to your right on the little itty
bitty wooden table there are pens out
there if you could put your name and
your email address phone number if you
don't get Brett's email that goes out
every week definitely want to fill this
out check the box that says send me
table newsletters also this is your
place to note if you're interested in
our small groups called meetups we have
a few and they would love to have you
visit their Meetup so you can also note
that on the card as you go into your
week ahead
you know messages like this can can
strike can trigger they can strike
chords they can cause you to think a lot
I don't want to assume how how the
message struck you one thing I know for
sure is
we can all use that reminder that we are
children of God
no matter what your week is like or
what's ahead so I'd love to send you out
with this benediction you can open your
hands just in a posture to receive these
words which I believe are true for every
single one of you in here
you are a child of God
this is true on your best day
and it's especially true on your worst
day
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy and you are accepted Just
As You Are
and go filled with God's holy spirit and
then desire to extend these same Gifts
of love
and grace and mercy to everybody you
come in contact with this week be
blessed have a good rest of your night
we hope to see you back here next Sunday
foreign
[Music]